so this lecture is about multiplying two
polynomials given by their coefficients
so let's say if X is a 0 plus a 1 X plus
2 you know it's always a problem should
I stop at n minus 1 or n anything and
then there's another one here and I want
to multiply them very fast how fast can
you do it sorry this was the lecture I
gave yesterday in today's money talks
are bad but if you want to sit here
again again it's fresh high dimensional
geometry
and concentration why is the question of
what this has to do with data science
I'm sure they're very good answers one
drawback of using the board is that I
don't get to put down outline of the
talk but I guess we should do that
anyway right so you know which parts you
can skip out for this here's a rough
outline please interrupt at any point
and I have several examples to work out
some more laborious than others and we
can certainly go different ways but
here's the outline so sort of one
general thing is that you've got lots of
these points and in high dimensional
space or a distribution and high
dimensional space data right and is
there some structure that will make
things easier for us so an aspect that
we will try to try to address is the
volume distribution just think of it as
our distribution of mass can you say
something about this in general so to
understand this we'll do a few examples
and then we'll get to the burn Mankowski
theorem which I will prove and then
apply if to get two different
interesting results so two apps and then
the frac opaline theorem which is takes
us from convex bodies to functions and
apply that once or twice I forget but
one or two perhaps
and then concentration of of of Lipchitz
functions functions that don't change
too much over over reasonable
distributions so the classical version
being levies constant concentration or
or lady concentration against and then
from this will go to the existence of
large Euclidean sections in these high
dimensional distributions or sets so
ours often call that Goreski or
generalized maretskiy theorem or it's
and that we'll take another look at the
last few topics and go to isoparametric
so that's the plan i've laid out so far
Fira if we run out of topics we can
branch further okay so just to see you
know the question you're asking is what
structure and high dimensions makes
problems tractable after one entry point
one motivation word structure and the
empirical answer seems to be some type
of so structure or practablity
this is only an empirical answer
it's a convexity and I'll put that in
quotes because it comes in different
guises and it's extensions now this is
certainly not a complete answer and just
so I say it at least once for example if
you want to solve linear equations over
GF 2 I don't know how to do it with a
convex method but as far as I know
that's the only country so anyway this
is the empirical answer so this seems to
be useful thinking and and and so we'll
do that so very quick one time recap so
we say K is convex and K is a subset
n-dimensional euclidean space dimension
will be N and which means that if two
points are in the set
so this buys us a lot of things but
let's see the first couple of examples I
want to do are about just a couple of
facts let's recap a couple of facts and
I dimension because things change a
little bit the phenomenon changes a bit
with dimension so fact 1 is just that
most of the volume this is actually got
little to do with convexity is near the
boundary
so I want to quantify this so you have
some set I'll call it K here but it
doesn't have to be convex and if I buy
mode by near the boundary I mean suppose
you look at a scaling of this 1 minus
epsilon K and all we're saying is that
the volume of 1 minus epsilon K no this
is n dimensional volume is 1 minus
epsilon to the N times the volume of K
so if epsilon is already like 1 over N
you're getting a constant fraction of
the water
right so this is already a constant
fraction
so you know if you had somebody you just
shrink it let's say it contains the unit
ball you shrink this by literally 1-1 a
1 minus 1 over n factor so the width of
this is actually less than 1 over N
because because I said it contains the
unit ball all right yeah it's a factor 1
minus 1 over N so then then you already
catch shaft 1 okay so most of it is near
the boundary this is actually maybe the
second most famous quote you know the
most famous one is one small step for a
man the second one is by embrava rania
everything interesting the convex body
happens near its boundary and the third
one you know every knows the third one
its back imagine if my laptop can't do
it
the universe can't do it or actually he
said the market but ok this is fact 1 ok
great now fact 2 so keep in mind fact
one because it will play a role in fact
- okay so this is visible still yeah ok
fact 2 is already maybe I should be
smart
- is that most of her I'll start with a
ball and I mean a Euclidean ball I don't
specify is near central hyperplane this
again we will quantify so I'm just
talking about the Euclidean ball
weekly norm less than equal to one and
take any central - I'm going to the
origin so n minus one dimension
hyperplane and we want to say that most
of the mass is near this is in a band in
a narrow band around
okay so let's quantify this as well get
familiar with these volume computations
so if I consider a section at distance
say T and you get the section there this
is the section here that's a lower
dimensional ball one the lower
dimensional ball and it's radius is
square root of 1 minus T squared so if I
look at the volume of the section at 0
right versus the volume of the section
at distance T from the origin this is
the the rich the radius has changed from
1 to square of 1 minus T squared so the
volume since these are n minus 1
dimensional objects now is going to
scale as 1 minus T Square to the 1/2 to
the power of n minus 1 so this one so
that's the rate at which it's scaling
which is about e to the minus
sorry familiar quantity is NT squared
okay like a Gaussian it's dropping off
so now it's so if I put T is 1 over root
n you already get about half its dropped
by half and it's dropping geometrically
so so by the time you reach constant
over root n distance so now we go to
these bands and this thickness here is
only about 1 over root n you already
picked up half a nice ball of radius 1 1
over root n you pick up a flash there
was nothing special about this choice of
hyperplane so it's true for every
central hype event well you know there
are sort of two in quartz paradoxes here
right how can you be both near the
boundary and near the central hyperplane
welcome to answer or yeah yeah so it's
because well even this within this band
most of the mass is actually near the
boundary so there's no contradiction I
mean this the band also has boundary and
if you look at those sections
everything's near the boundary you could
pause this in a slightly different way
which is to say suppose I had two of
these bands right where is the
intersection it's also near the boundary
and it did so no contradiction but yes
it's it's gets highly concentrated okay
I want to just while we're doing this we
can we can see that this computation
these computations also let us talk
about what's the volume of the cap so
what's outside the systems and so that
drops off roughly like this e to the
minus n T squared over 2 because it's
determined essentially by the by the
bounding section after that it's
dropping off fast but now you can ask
this more generally let's say it lets me
take a different shape say a cube so
that we can do the computations
explicitly again and I take some
Direction some unit vector say use the
unit vector and we ask what's the
distribution of mass along you same type
of question so now we're asking what is
the probability
that for a random X from the cube new
dot X is let's say greater than T and
it's again centered at the origin okay
and U is a unit vector this and now this
again we can we can we can do using
basic sure enough style bounds because
the X's are the coordinates of the cube
are independent the XS are independent
and so again this will also fall like
use a minus and T squared no no no N now
because because these are unit vectors
did I get that right you say it again
yeah use the unit vector and I clicked X
from the unit hypercube here so the
variance of this is just saying that if
you go out so the standard deviation is
1 if you go out t standard deviations
you will get e to the minus T squared
over 2 so so you have this similar
phenomenon here to the previous example
with the two bands yeah
how come into section is on the boundary
I mean they seem to picture it seems
that since there are there oh but this
picture is so low dimensional right yeah
so if you're in very high dimension the
most of the map think of the band not as
a band through the through the through
the ball but just as an actual ring in
lower dimension because that's where
most of the masses I see there's most
means overwhelming yeah
between towards the measure you're using
for people at the moment it's just
Euclidian volume we will talk about
general measures yeah okay so so these
these raise certain natural general
questions right I mean it's something
like this going to be true for some
family of bodies and distributions or
what can we say what what rates do we
get these are still questions being
pursued by the field in full generality
but we have some nice answers and some
nice tools to get there the first of
these is perhaps the Brahmin cow skinny
cow ski and to state the theorem I have
to develop one tool which is how to add
two of these sets so suppose I have two
sets a B and this you're not saying
anything about convex
they're just compact so I can talk about
their volume and they're bounded and
they are subsets of RN so the Bezier
Mankowski some something you would have
seen if you've been doing lower bounds
also a plus b is just the set of all X
plus y where X is in a and y
so if I were to add a square plus a
circle I get you know I'll start at the
square and add a little circle just add
a circle to every point of the square
okay
the position of the circle doesn't
matter right these things are it's it's
independent of their pivot just adding a
circle per square you get the same thing
additive combinatorics additive geometry
so so okay so given this and then
scaling of course is well defined if I
want to talk about scaling a set where
lambda is just a then this is just a set
of lambda X where X is in it
so so the motivation for the theorem is
if I have two sets and they have volume
now I take their sum like this or take a
convex combination of them what's the
volume into again you so that could be
very very different things depending on
the shapes of the sets but you expect
that it shouldn't be too small because
you're taking to meet all these
combinations right the set size of this
sum shouldn't be too small that's that's
what the theorem is going to say that
for a B subset of RN and compact and
lambda multiple contracts combination
multiplier the volume of lambda a plus 1
minus lambda B to the 1 over n is at
least lambda x value of 1 over n plus 1
minus lambda times volume to the 1 over
n function is concave
well we'll get a minute but this is this
justice this is a statement about two
sets right now and any multiply now
equivalently right so so well let's
let's prove this hope can't forget to
you can always give me the signal to
speed up it you've seen the proof in the
previous lectures I don't think you have
right yeah so by just replacing lambda a
by a and 1 minus lambda B by B it's
sufficient to prove that volume of a
sorry a plus B to the 1 over N is at
least lambda volume of a
what's your hand there yeah plus okay
got it but so how should we do this
proof suffice us to show this so so
first let's do it for a very simple
family of bodies which will be disk you
boys boxes and so suppose a is just a
cuboid where the axis lengths are a1 a2
and so on so it's 0 a 1 Cross 1 and B
similarly has axis lengths B 1 through B
and then the inequality we want to prove
is what and a plus B is just the box
with lengths a AI plus bi so the
inequality we want to prove is just
product over I of AI plus bi to the 1
over N is at least right AI to the 1
over N
almost a million right so well yeah it
is so let's just divide so what you want
is that this is at least
ái over AI plus bi to the 1 over N
so far so good and yet need to show this
now we will use the work inequality
have fun if you haven't seen it before
where there's a product and there's a
some will turn this product into a sum
but what I want to say is that this is
dominated by the sum over I of the these
things one over N times that okay
so AI over AI plus bi just Alice Matic
mean is bigger than Johnny Trigg mean
these are all non-negative numbers and
same thing for that so I might as well
put it over here that's what this is one
okay so it's true for boxes but we have
to we want to show it for arbitrary sets
with volume now one way to define volume
is divide space into boxes and count all
the boxes that are fully contained and
then you take the size of the boxes down
to zero and you multiply by the volume
of each box so that's one way to define
volume in fact so it'll be enough for us
to show this for a union a box is a
union of boxes and B is Union on boxes
then we'd like to show that this
inequality still holds
yeah so how should we do it a is a union
of boxes the boxes that constitute a
them sell a a are disjoined boxes to
constitute B are disjoint and we would
like to show that this holds for the
union of boxes so the it's going to be
by induction on the total number so this
is for a finite union that's good enough
for taking the limit so we wanted to
show that for any finite union so let's
say the total number of box this is some
number and we're going to do an
induction on the number of these boxes
okay so for one box we already know it's
true right or even one box each so one
box each we have it so the base case is
done so now for the inductive case you
just need a way to cut it into smaller
numbers of boxes right so I've got both
boxes so for a you know I'm just
thinking of them as a union of boxes
right they don't even have to make up
power remember it's just a compact set
it doesn't have to be connected and then
we're boxes for B somewhere and how
should i do induction there to somehow
partition them to get two sets with
fewer numbers of boxes so I can apply
the same no so simple claim is that
there exists an axis parallel cut
parallel hyperplane
such that so let's just take the boxes
for a such that each side contains at
least one complete box
each side of H say H is the hyperplane
contains one complete box of it
so is that clear one dimension it's
clear right because otherwise they are
going to be intersecting pairwise okay
so what about in higher dimension
pretend all these are the same color
dimension yes but you know they might
intersect yeah yeah we want that what we
want is a cut so in this picture for
example this would be good right I mean
this is great give us a complete
partition but even this would be good
because this has one complete box a look
now the point is that why you were
saying there exists one you see in one
if I just sweep in one direction there
might not be one and it could be that
all the boxes are intersecting along one
half plane so it could be that no matter
where you go you're not able to get a
complete box on both sides so right but
that means that there is yes so the
second just to clarify the second
vertical one does not have each complete
box of pipe I don't need of both types
sorry so this time is only about one
type so yeah yeah I should draw another
figure with the same color but yes it
sounds like it should be the case that
for every pair of boxes there is just an
axis parallel - quite a separate sure
yes all right so he's saying just take
two boxes and there's going to be a
plane that separates them otherwise they
have a point in common yeah good so so
so we have we have at least one
hyperplane cart which separates this so
let's just apply that to be way off to
the side that has all whole boxes on one
side so we need a complete box or on
both sides of the play of the cart okay
but that's not what your claim says it
says each side of the hyperplane has one
complete
so so let's say we've got this cut and
there's at least one complete box here
but of course there could be lots of
boxes that are partially going this way
right and there's at least one complete
box here now this is just a so far I get
to place B now first for these boxes
that are being intersected we'll just
break them up into two right so each
side still has fewer boxes because
you've lost one box you might have kept
the rest okay
and what about B so what we do with B is
remember we get to place B anywhere we
want because a and B the relative
placement doesn't matter for the purpose
of volume so we want to place B with the
following convenient constraint and B
maybe all of them intersect I don't care
maybe maybe all of them intersect but
the constraint for B is the following
that and you know they might overlap
doesn't really matter because things for
B is that so this half plane edge is
such that let's call one side a plus and
B plus I really should stick to the
color and then a minus and B minus
should be cutting also the same yes
there is one of one hyperplane which was
the one we chose for the purpose of
cutting a and now I'm just taking all of
these arrangement and placing it in a
certain way okay translating it to place
in a certain way in fact just a
translation and the translation is such
that the volume of a plus let's say
divided by the volume of B plus this
ratio is equal to the volume of a minus
divided by volume of it behind
that's so same as volume of a movie
we're just keeping the fractional volume
on to that's it that's it so that
obviously is just by translation of B
okay now that we have that you can go
back to the proof we want to bound what
the volume of a plus B the one over on
the a is the union of all the boxes
region so it's at least going to be
let's just use the lower bound we get
from each side separately that's also so
it's at least going to be the volume of
eight plus plus D plus one over N minus
D minus
now we can use induction because these
have fewer numbers of boxes and we know
that this is at least volume of a plus
to the 1 over N
okay okay so I could be the definition
of a lesson
whatever falls on one side of the
hyperplane is a plus whatever falls on
the other side is a - so boxes that
intersect we cut them and placed okay
the portion of them Martha a plus B plus
and a minus plus B minus one is this yes
but because of because of the we can we
can these volumes are not overlapping
they're actually okay so here what
should we do here let's say I take
volume of V Plus to the 1 over N so then
I've got
are so good what do the same thing here
this proof will finish on this board so
don't be alarmed
it was the way why what is the point of
this these yeah these are the same and
they're the same as volume of a or
volume of B so therefore we've got one
plus volume of a over volume of P both
won over ends times volume of B plus
plus volume of B minus to the 1 over N
we're doing something fishy
it's all that is times is harder to see
it's okay let's in how many actually a
lot of my hands concave right right
right so so all I'm thinking that this
Plus this is that so I should make this
inequality volume up no no I can't do
that
I'm not doing to the one over here to
one over it yes okay and so now we've
got
okay so it's just an induction on the
number of already recorded ex to be
introduced this one here this one here
yeah all because we're saying that the
volume contributed by a plus plus B plus
and a minus plus B minus are disjoint
we're not over counting any anymore but
that was their market so you just take
the hyperplane to be less than or equal
to zero
yeah yeah taking this hyperplane to be
whatever x1 equal to zero then there is
no interference of intersection between
these masses
so how do you guarantee this hyperplane
always exists that's my that ratio yeah
so you see the relative placement of a
and B doesn't matter so we picked the
hyperplane to subdivide a so that we get
one complete box on each side and then
we can and of course we can translate a
so that this hyperplane is at zero now
we take B and we can do whatever we want
with it not rotation sorry actually you
can do any of that but all translations
all that will matter say you start
completely on one side and you move it
till you get the right ratio
intermediate values okay so this is a
burn Mankowski let's see a couple of
applications of it and then
so what application is is - again - to
talk about the distribution of mass of
convex bodies like we were doing with
the early examples so what if you had a
convex body okay okay and I'm interested
in the distribution of mass along some
direction say this direction and what is
the distribution of mass of these
sections as you go along now
so let's look at these sections there's
a section at each position along this
axis and let's say think of that as a
this section is a of X it's a section at
X now the section and this is a a of Y
these are n minus 1 dimensional sections
the section at lambda X plus 1 minus
lambda Y right so this section here
convex combination of these lambda is
and 0 1 contains lambda times the
section at X plus 1 minus lambda times
the section at Y just by convexity right
so the by convexity every combination of
these two sections must be in the set
this combination always gives you 6
sections exactly on this set so this
must be true therefore the volume of
this section a at the convex combination
is is how much just using this and
applying run winkowsky to this set which
is a which is a convex Minkowski
combination of two sets gives us that
this volume to the 1 over N and minus 1
because these are n minus 1 dimensional
sections is at least lambda times the
volume of a X to the 1 over N minus 1
plus 1 minus lambda times
the volume of a y1 / - okay so the
volume at a combination section convex
combination section is to the 1 over n
minus 1 is the concave function there's
an even nicer way to interpret this
which is let's do the following
symmetrization where we replace each
section with a with a ball and minus 1
dimensional ball of the same volume and
centered on this line so we're going
from this with this picture where this
section ax just becomes a n minus 1
dimensional ball and n minus 1
dimensional ball and and so on can they
are all centered now each of these has a
radius right let's call that radius
function R of X what does this say about
the radius function concave the radius
function is concave because volume to
the 1 over N minus 1 will be some fixed
function of n times the radius the
volume is radius to the n minus 1 for
now we'll turn it into that literally by
saying setting the volume G so the so
the conclusion corollary the radius
function along any projection is
contained
what is this these three pictures oh
sorry
this section here which was some
arbitrary convex body I'm replacing it
with a n minus 1 dimensional sphere of
the same volume so right and it has some
radius so now it's a completely along
this axis it's a it's a spherically
symmetric picture so that gives you some
radius function now I can erase these
and just look at the radius function and
this various functions concave so the
Rays function is the volume of the
cross-section to the one oh whatever
yes up to constant doesn't constant
doesn't matter yeah so yeah the
definition of the radius function is
just volume of V of X to the 1 over n
minus 1 because it's the radius of it's
proportional to the radius of n minus 1
dimensional ball with the same volume
but this is what we have in mind only
see convex right you can't have dips
will go along any direction and that's
true in this whole sense yeah
because is there some interpretation to
what this is the radius or something yes
the radius of this ball so imagine that
I replaced I don't know you have a cube
I'm going along some direction of the
cube say even an even an axis parallel
direction first replace each lower
dimensional cube with a ball it has some
radius along an axis direction that's
constant this is telling something about
the shape of a little convex body oh
there are only in terms of how it's
increasing and decreasing yeah in this
what this one-dimensional projection
it's capturing the one-dimensional
projection it's capturing this marginal
so a second application of this perhaps
this is a corollary the second
application is a theorem on its own does
the radius function say something about
like the expected distance from the
center conditioned on what section
you're on or something unfortunately not
because when you place it like a sphere
here like a ball you actually bring it
as close as possible to the origin for
the same volume among you know it brings
it as close as possible so if you
replaced say a cube section with a ball
sections right the distances will shrink
for the same volume
you know this say Volume one the cube
only needs to have side length one the
ball will have radius constant root N
and yes so could give some rough
estimate but in general notes not so
here is a second application which will
which will address some of these issues
it's it's called grunt bombs theorem
which says that if you take any convex
body
then any
half-space containing its center of
gravity for any half-space containing
the center of gravity okay any
half-space HC the volume of h intersect
k so the volume of in the half space is
at least 1 over e times the volume okay
you can't get too little volume on
either side of the Central Valley so
this picture here here's the center of
gravity I take any cart
each side has at least one ovary yeah
under the function actually there is a
function of n we will derive it but it
tends to 1 over e when n goes so for any
fixed dimension it's slightly better
than this but let but this theorem is
also true for example I haven't yet
introduced la concave functions but it's
also true for any la concave function
and then indeed you get 1 over e you can
just take for example the exponential
distribution
okay so we have all the tools we need to
prove this in fact we just need the run
winkowsky theorem how should we proceed
this is at heart of a one-dimensional
problem yes it is 4/4 depending on the
dimension know one of them e plus 0.01
oh no no no no because if you cut the
distribution like I mean just a uniform
distribution
yeah no it's still going to be we'll see
what it's sort of it's going to be 1
minus 1 over n plus 1 to the N now we
will derive the worst example you don't
it's not just a bound so your answer you
will be completely happy by him what
should we do what you what should step 1
be
I claim this is a one-dimensional
problem which dimension we have fixed
the hyperplane edge so you might as well
fix it cuz you wanna prove for everyone
yes normal to that then let's look at
the direction normal to the hyperplane
okay and then what should we do we are
interested in the mass let's say on one
side let's say on the left I want to
prove the little mass on the left is at
least 1 over E right so and then I'm
making sure it passes through the center
of gravity so the expectation is see it
now let's simplify this body right
because we only care about this one
dimension margin how should we simplify
by doing that yes so we'll do this
symmetrization which will take us to
something that maybe looks I like that
like that okay but now it's a symmetric
object still a convex body in n
dimension but every cross-section is
just a ball of different radius okay so
so now this and further this is concave
this radius is actually concave okay and
we have the center of gravity somewhere
now I want to do two operations just so
it doesn't seem like I'm going to
convert this into the worst possible
body and we'll show that for the worst
body you know sometimes you get to do
this you actually the proof actually
takes you to the worst example so what
do you imagine the worst example is I
mean it's not gonna be a cube right for
a cube you've cut in the middle you're
always wearing it half half right it
should be some kind of asymmetric body
straight 1/4 size not quite
we are the questions in this volumes
that you have one is an N minus 1
dimensional volume the other is an
international so every section is n
minus 1 dimensional the volume of the
whole thing is just the integral of
those n minus 1 dimensions so in the
Equality above the chip we have n
dimensional whose it's a half space okay
yeah sorry
baskets yeah
yeah yeah so we'll reduce this to a cone
okay now right so even in two dimensions
if you took a triangle and cut through
the center of gravity you don't get half
a little bit less than half the center
of gravity yeah
the center of gravity is just imagine
the uniform this is a compact it's a
convex part if the compact set we can
talk about it's the uniform distribution
over this so I guess I just mean the
integral over all points in your set of
the uniform distribution so one over
volume of K it'll be the average of all
the points
okay so yeah so for even if or even a
triangle you see this is similar right
this picture is similar you might
remember that this distance is 2/3 of
the total if I cut through the through
the through the center so this volume is
going to be how much four lines not half
but four lines you're scaling the whole
triangle down by two-thirds so here what
we're going to do is replace first the
left half with a cone okay so that cone
will keep the same base here but I'm
going to make it a complete cone like
that
of the same volume so the volume of this
cone is the same as the volume of the
whatever was on the left with the same
base now I claim the center of gravity
maybe it moved which way will it move
only to the left
I created mass to below all right that's
a I mean it's a song okay so what should
we do with that with that with the right
half now work it to the right to bounce
it so what I want to do is make this
continue this cone as far as I need to
to make it a cone and the volume is
still the same now claim you can do this
why because it's concave right what
you're doing here is a convex extension
of what you have left you it's allowed
to do it this funk radius function is
concave it'll never overshoot your
picture okay so now you've got a cone
and again the the center of gravity
might have moved left which only makes
matters worse for you potentially so
let's assume there was no change we've
got a cone now I have to really do the
computation for a cone now for and this
is just a perfectly symmetric cone so
the center of gravity will be a distance
n over n plus one from from here so you
are shrinking it by one - I mean this is
n over n plus one of the total to the
power of n that's the ratio
which is bigger than quality I can put
straight away
that's the election it's random through
the center of Miss OH
then it will be concentrated near one
half and we will prove that by the end
of that because then you need a
concentration it will be near 1/2
because it's expectation is 1/2 I will
concentrate near its expectation for a
random light this is this is exactly so
even for a for a for a cone if I were to
pick it randomly it will be very close
to 1/2 very good yeah what's the proper
angle for the cones in order to make it
worse kiss doesn't matter every comes
the same yeah because it's a scaling
that all the reused is the skin
so they serve gravity the point that
that maximizes this one every factor I'm
not sure to me oh yeah oh I see you know
like that characteristic oh I see
so what is the best point and so that
any cut through it maximizes that III
know I I don't know the answer to that
but I think it should be different for
different bodies yeah so no reason why
it should be center of gravity
so I have five more minutes right so
maybe I'll start off on the on back of a
line where we're planning to prove it
it's proof will just use run winkowsky
okay so at least I can state the theorem
here begin the proof will continue with
that yeah
and put any other questions are welcome
so now we move to functions from I mean
we were dealing with functions but zero
one functions one of your in the set
zero if you're outside the set now we're
going to move to more general functions
and so the statement of the line the
theorem which is equivalent one to the
burn Ninkasi can prove one from the
other and both ways is is is the
following you have three functions now F
G H which are n-dimensional and
non-negative and they have the following
property that at any point and for any
lambda which is again like a convex
multiplier H of lambda X plus 1 minus
lambda Y is at least f of X to the power
lambda times G of Y to the power 4 minus
4 that's the that's the assumption on
these functions so the function value of
this the log of H is at least the
average of these ok under these
assumptions we get that the integral of
H on all of our n is at least integral
of F for the lambda times the integral
of G
for months that's the conclusion
[Music]
so maybe maybe since they won't have
time to actually prove it before the
break what I can instead do is the first
application like why does this make
sense then so application one is
following so if we had just one function
f we say it's log concave if its
logarithm is concave so f is a function
from RN to non-negative numbers and it
satisfies this property that F of any
convex combination is at least the
geometric average at the two points that
you are combining alright so the log of
F is concave these functions show up
everywhere though the indicator
functions of convex bodies Gaussian
densities you know anything with a
convex function e to the minus convex
function here this low concave you can
multiply them clearly if you multiply
you still preserve this property
multiplication is preserves low
concavity what is this telling us track
of our line learn implies that so this
is that that marginals
our la concave so you know if you take a
Gaussian and you project it you get a
Gaussian distribution still la concave
it's still true could be a very
complicated me if you take a convex body
projected it's not a convex body anymore
but if you think of it as a function
it's still a lock on a function and more
generally on equivalently convolutions
so convolution of two law concave
functions preserves concavity
okay so to see the first one apply this
lemma with F G H equal to F this is
satisfied by definition of low concavity
and now it's saying that you get to do
this but before you apply let's say I
want to prove that a particular marginal
say a marginal along x1 up to XK is lock
on K so I just integrate away XK plus 1
to xn this is it you you pick so so
capital F of x1 through XK is equal to
this
this is the marginal along x1 through XK
you could do margins along and so so
it's like a projection right you're
projecting to the first K coordinates
and the claim is that projection
preserves lock on Capital y apply this
right you do you define this function
here you can see that this this F
satisfies what we want there for the
integrals up to six fix x1 through XK
and for each fixed x1 through XK pick up
a line there tells you that you satisfy
which one therefore capital F is not
Bank a convolution proof is very similar
what is convolution and I will stop
there convolution is integral of f of
say Z times G of X minus Z DZ ok and
this integral is over Z this is the
function value at some X and we want to
say that if F and G are both log concave
then cap laugh is also lock on K Y think
of this product function as one log
concave function say capital G of X and
Z and it's not concave because this is
La concave and that's low concave
practice law countries and now kept left
is just a marginal you're integrating
away half the quarter once up is a
subset of the coordinates so convolution
is back on K projections of knock on
gate functions along K which is a very
useful problem yes
instead of you - ready / are in could it
be a babysit
maybe it lands up in the second half
because we'll prove it
and then we'll let's check
[Applause]